Unreal Engine 5 Animation Mode is a mode that exposes new tools, panels, and editor behaviors
that assist with animation workflows.
This essentially turns Unreal Engine into a toolkit for making or editing animations.
When using this mode and animating with something like Control Rig, it's going to offer a more
animation focused editor experience by exposing tabs that aid with the selecting of controls,
transform displays, and launching of tools related to animation.
Animation mode is mainly dependent on using Control Rig within Sequencer.
Therefore, a basic knowledge of Sequencer is required to get the most out of this.
Now, normally we would pop right into a demo of us utilizing this, but because this is
a tool that exposes more tools, I'll show you how to activate it, but we don't have a lot of
example content because that is very dependent on what you are doing with this particular tool set.
So let's just pop over here into the editor.
Now, I am in a bit of a different example here.
I am in the FK example here for Control Rig, and the reason I want to do that is I do want to have at least
something to populate in the windows when I select the tool set.
So if I come down here to my selection mode and come to Animation, we can see here that under my constraints,
you can see that I have two undefined ones right here that are representative of this right here.
The other tools that I have here are things for poses, tweens, snappers, trails, animation layers,
and temporarily adjusting pivots, but notice that I also have my animation, Outliner animation details as well.
So again, this is not necessarily a tool that does one specific thing.
What this mode does is it adjusts the way the editor interacts, giving you a more animation focused workflow.